JAKE ARCHIBALD: But here we go.
I'm going to invite
the panelists on stage
as I introduce them,
the leadership panel.
I'm going to have Rahul
Roy-Chowdhury, the product
manager, director on Chrome.
If you want to give a wave
as you enter the stage.
That's this guy.
We've got Darin Fisher.
You don't have to come on one
by one, but you can if you want.
[LAUGHS] Yeah.
You get a certificate.
You all get a certificate.
Darin's the VP of
Engineering on Chrome,
who you'll recognize from the
opening of the conference.
Avni Shah, VP of Product
Management on Chrome.
Grace Kloba, the Lead
Engineer for Chrome on Mobile.
And reprising his role of
Greg Simon, it's Greg Simon.
GREG SIMON: That's right.
Thank you.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Engineering
Director on Chrome.
And I am Jake Archibald,
the Chief Vice Director
of important Jake business.
GREG SIMON: Just promoted.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah, so
you've been posing questions
to this panel throughout
the last couple of days,
but please don't stop there.
Chris Wilson is
monitoring this document
and is able to
feed me information
using the power of the internet.
You can add stuff on
to the moderator panel
or just tweet it.
But of course, we have
the dreaded microphone
in the middle.
So if you want to
queue up there,
we can get questions
going live as well.
Right.
Let's move on to
the first question.
So Chrome-packaged apps
and especially extensions
are a really popular part
of the desktop browser.
When do we get them on Android?
RAHUL ROY-CHOWDHURY:
So I'll take that.
There are a couple of things.
Chrome apps can be
ported to Android and iOS
through the Cordova framework.
And so that continues.
It's been supported
for a while, and we
will continue to support that.
Chrome extensions
are not something
that we have ported
to Android or actually
any mobile platform.
And we have no plans at
this point to do that.
And if you guys have
compelling use cases
and you want to talk about
why this is something
you'd be interested in,
I'd love to hear more.
But no plans as of now.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So is
there anything specific
that's holding us back on
particularly extensions?
I'm not saying I want
AdBlock on my mobile,
because that would be bad.
But I do?
No. [LAUGHS]
GREG SIMON: That's true.
There is one technical
reason, and that is RAM.
Chrome uses a lot
of RAM, of course.
And the thing about extensions
is they will inject JavaScript
from the page, and
suddenly, it can't
collect, because the structure
that the developer thought
they had free was now being
retained by an extension.
And this kind of snowballs.
And then there's lots
of RAM, and it's used.
And it's, like, unknown
what the actual problem is.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I suppose we
saw Firefox go through this.
People would start
to say Firefox
was slow when it was very
rarely Firefox's problem.
It was actually extensions
that were making it slow.
And I suppose on mobile,
there's less wriggle room there.
GREG SIMON: Whenever a
family member comes up
to me at Thanksgiving
and says, Chrome
is running slow, I instantly
open up an Incognito window
and say, OK, try now.
GRACE KLOBA: Yeah,
I just want to add
to what Greg said
about the memory.
So for Chrome, like, a render
process, browser process,
and the old extensions
running their own process,
and then on mobile, you just
cannot have all this processing
of foreground
without being killed.
So we try to make Chrome run
as best as it can for the user.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So V8 was
an absolute revolution
in terms of JavaScript
performance,
but today we're seeing more
ES6 features in Firefox
than Chrome.
It's certainly [? unstable, ?]
like [? not ?] [? behind ?]
[? flags. ?] What gives?
GREG SIMON: Well, it's true.
We are a bit behind
in ES6 features in V8
when you look at other browsers.
But if you look at what we've
done over the past six months,
we've changed our game a lot.
We've shipped [? maps ?]
[? and sets. ?] We have a team
up in San Francisco
that's completing classes
in JavaScript now, so you're
going to see that at some
point.
But remember, V8's priority
first is that speed,
and the speed games in
JavaScript have not,
like, let up.
And we continue to
invest heavily in that.
That's very important to us.
DARIN FISHER: And shout-out
to chromestatus.com,
where you can actually see
the set of ES6 features that
are currently implemented,
like lexical scoping and so on.
GREG SIMON: Yeah, exactly.
In Chrome, yeah.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So
question to the audience.
What ES6 features
do you think we
should be giving priority to?
What's your favorites in
the new set of JavaScript?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Promises.
AUDIENCE: Arrows!
GREG SIMON: So Promises are--
DARIN FISHER: Arrow
functions are underway.
GREG SIMON: Yup.
AUDIENCE: Generators.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I'm sorry.
What was that?
Shout that out again.
AUDIENCE: Generators.
JAKE ARCHIBALD:
Generators just landed.
Generators has just landed.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
DARIN FISHER: Way to turn
that question around.
[LAUGHTER]
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So
completely fair,
when I said that,
I thought, someone
say "generators," because
we have a good story there.
GREG SIMON: I heard
someone say modules.
I would also love
modules, too, but the spec
is, like, kind of
all over the place.
And so we want to let it
stabilize a bit first.
DARIN FISHER: Yeah, to
echo what Greg said,
we really want to be
very thoughtful as we're
extending V8's
capabilities, because we
have to be very focused on
making sure that we're putting
out high-quality implementation,
performance implementation.
A lot of times, when you're
adding these features,
you're adding complexity.
We want to do it right.
So it takes time to do it right.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: And
someone said Promises.
Well, we've got Promises
[? in stable, ?] but
it's really fun when
you mix together
Generators and
Promises, because you
can write what looks like
synchronous code or a very
simple flow.
So that's really
worth checking out.
And for me, the
ES7 feature I want
is async functions,
which kind of makes
that part of the language.
You get to await
a promise, and it
will sort of asynchronously
pause that execution flow.
It's absolutely brilliant.
Anyway, sorry.
Hi, guys.
[LAUGHTER]
So Chrome DevTools,
they took what
Firebug started and
kind of ran with it.
And I don't think
it's biased to say
that it became the definitive
web debugging tool.
But now Firefox and
IE have caught up,
and they're innovating.
What are we doing?
GREG SIMON: So
yeah, I'm extremely
proud of the Chrome
DevTools team.
Every time I open
it up, it seems
like there's something new
there that is like magical.
It's really amazing.
But of course, with
all these features,
it can be hard to find what
you're looking for sometimes.
We talked a bit
about this at BlinkOn
two weeks ago, where we
talked about the big projects
we were going to do
in Blink in 2015.
And one of them is about
really informing you guys,
as developers, as to when
you make your frame time,
meaning you're able to do
all your layout, painting,
and JavaScript in less
than 16 milliseconds,
or when you don't.
So look for things in 2015
around more notifications
about when you're going off
into the weeds, so to speak.
JAKE ARCHIBALD:
Is there anything
like specific in terms
of mobile or performance
that we expect to
see in DevTools soon?
Do you have a particular--
I suppose if--
GREG SIMON: No.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: No, OK. [LAUGHS]
GREG SIMON: Well, no.
No, but I mean, much of the
work of the web platform
team over the past
nine months has all
been about just doing less.
We want to get it
out of the way,
so you guys can run as much
JavaScript as you want,
which is sort of a joke.
But what's most important is,
we want to get it out of the way
so that when something
is slow, you can fix it
and you don't have to
rely on filing a bug,
and twelve weeks later,
some kind of release.
We want to give
more power to you.
JAKE ARCHIBALD:
So with DevTools,
I find that when I'm using OS X,
which is the operating system I
use day to day, I
find that there's
a lot of amazing features
there with zero discovery.
I keep promising
myself I'm going
to spend a day just
holding down the Option key
and clicking everything to
find out even more stuff.
I'm hearing from some developers
that they feel the same
about Chrome
DevTools, that there's
a lot of great
stuff in there that
isn't widely used,
due to discovery.
Is there something
we can do about that?
GREG SIMON: I mean, I've used
a lot of DevTools in my career.
They're all kind of like this.
I probably shouldn't
call them out by name,
but yeah, sure, you're right.
We can probably do more.
There are articles
on HTML5 Rocks.
Maybe we can expand those a bit.
But this is a DevTool.
It's going to show
low-level stuff.
It's not going to be maybe as
soft and cuddly as a web page,
but it's not meant for that.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So in terms
of new web platform stuff,
we're launching Service
Worker pretty aggressively.
DARIN FISHER: Yay.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yay.
But there's still
some disagreements
between the browsers and
ongoing [? inspection. ?]
And we're wanting to push
push messaging, deploy push
messaging, while
there's kind of still
no standard for the server
to serve a messaging part.
Are we doing something wrong
by pushing that aggressively
before we've had total agreement
that there's definitely nothing
there we can do
with these specs?
DARIN FISHER: I
think definitely,
there's a balancing act here.
It's important for us to
be aggressive in the sense
that developers are
really demanding
us to try to figure out
and solve these problems.
And Service Worker is
definitely something
that's been in work, under
development for quite awhile,
actually, as you know, Jake.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: But
it's relative, isn't it?
It's been like a year
and a half, which
I think, in terms of spec time,
that's only like 20 minutes.
DARIN FISHER: Yes, this is true.
But it's been
developed in the open.
There's been a
lot of discussions
and a lot of
collaboration actually
with folks from Mozilla and
product teams at Google who
are very hungry
for these features.
So the feedback
loop is pretty good.
I know that ultimately, we
want to try to ship this thing,
and we're probably going to be
the first browser to ship it.
That means we're taking
on some risk, risk
that when other browser
vendors go off to ship,
we'll be slightly different.
And that's definitely
a risk that we
are aware of,
concerned about, want
to make sure that
we do right, and not
create complications on the
platform, because ultimately,
that's not great.
GREG SIMON: We're also taking
a very layered approach
to shipping Service
Worker, and there
are parts of the spec that are
not quite gelled yet, Jake.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Sorry.
GREG SIMON: But that's OK.
It's OK.
But we wanted to ship
a minimal-- what's
the minimal useful piece
that we can get out there,
to show that we're serious and
that you guys have something
to use?
If you have any
questions or you're
curious about how we actually
decide to ship things,
definitely check out the
mailing list blink-dev.
It's a public list
where people that
work on the Blink
engine trade notes.
But also, there is
a process on there
called Intent to Implement
and Intent to Ship.
And so when you, as a
developer, come in and say,
I want to work on and I want to
add feature x to the platform,
so I send an email with a
template to the whole group,
saying, Intent to Implement,
which is meant to be low
friction, just sort of a PSA.
But then when you're
ready to turn it on
and you have to send
an Intent to Ship--
And we aren't special
because we're Google.
We send these as well.
And you will see Googlers
coming on there, going, you're
going to ship
Service Worker now?
Are you crazy?
And so we have to actually
explain all of our reasoning.
And that's all public.
It's all out there,
and you can read it.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah.
And if you have any
specific questions
about the flow we're
doing or anything else,
the scary microphone is there.
It's not that scary,
but it's anyone's.
Yeah, if you've got a
question, go for it.
Yeah.
I think with Service Worker
and certainly other specs
as well, that we could sit on
this thing for another three
years, and we could come up
with a slightly better API.
We could probably come up
with a slightly cleaner spec.
But ultimately,
the result would be
no Service Worker for anyone.
GREG SIMON: Exactly.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So I think I'm
kind of happy with what we're
doing, pushing
that stuff forward.
And we saw this with
Promises as well.
We'd have to sort
of make a change
to our live thing of Promises,
but we knew from the data
that it wasn't going to
break existing sites.
GREG SIMON: Yeah.
I mean, no one on this team is
interested in being reckless.
DARIN FISHER: But you
make a good point.
Through Chrome's Dev channel
and the usage counters
that we have for
folks who opt in,
we're able to understand
adoption of these things
and understand the
risk to rolling out
slight variations of features
that we've already shipped.
And you can see these kinds of
changes being announced also
on blink-dev.
And people, again,
are trying to be
very thoughtful of the
impact that may have.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Cool.
Question from the audience?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I am a beginner.
What is the best web
application editor you
recommend, especially
for Chrome?
GREG SIMON: What is
the best web editor?
Like to--
DARIN FISHER: I really like
using Vim, but anyways.
GREG SIMON: This is so funny.
There have been so many
failed attempts over history
to create the
ultimate web editor.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I think
it's-- I use Sublime Text 2.
I haven't even
moved up to 3 yet.
Well, because I think
because of the amount of time
a developer spends in
a particular editor,
it's like moving house.
You can't just get up and go.
It needs to be--
because even if--
DARIN FISHER: Those keystrokes
I learned in 1993, they
continue to serve me well.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Right.
[LAUGHTER]
GREG SIMON: One other
thing is that there's
so many different ways to do the
same thing on the web platform,
right?
And that doesn't
really lend itself
well to some kind of ID that
will do everything for you.
Usually, popular IDs
take you down one path.
And the web doesn't
really have much of that.
I mean, it doesn't
even have a theme.
It just has sort of
a white rectangle.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I'm
super fascinated
by some of the
editors we're seeing
built on top of
web technologies.
Because it's this idea
of even as a beginner,
you could start to use them.
And then as you learn more
about the web platform,
you can start to
change the editor
to be more like how
you would work it.
You can sort of learn
the web platform
through the web platform.
DARIN FISHER: I feel like
[? jspin ?] has almost
become like a verb on our team.
GREG SIMON: That's true.
That's true.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah,
I love [? jet spin. ?]
AUDIENCE: We have a
consensus over here.
Nobody's mentioned Chrome
DevTools as an editor,
and it actually
does an amazing job.
GREG SIMON: That's true.
Yeah.
So I believe the
reason that they
put that in is because the
Chrome DevTools editor uses
that to work on DevTools,
I'm pretty sure.
DARIN FISHER: This is true.
They actually do self-hosted
development of DevTools.
It's fantastic.
Fantastically awesome.
GREG SIMON: In
fact, they even had
some sort of plug-in that would
save things out to the local--
anyway.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Good.
We'll take another
question from the audience.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
So there's sort of-- I guess
if you think about mobile web
and parity with
native, there are
sort of three different ways
you can attack it-- parity
in performance, parity in
capabilities-- so Bluetooth,
those things-- and then
parity in distribution--
so app store, on the same
level with native apps,
seeing web applications.
Are there plans around
that to merge the Chrome
Store into the Play Store?
Anything along those lines?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Hm.
RAHUL ROY-CHOWDHURY: I
can take a crack at that.
We don't have plans to merge the
Chrome Web Store and Play Store
or bring the Chrome Web
Store to mobile just yet.
But you make a good point
with the general idea of,
how do we find ways to
bridge the gap between web
apps and native apps?
You've heard of all
the things we're
doing in terms of performance,
in terms of capabilities.
Discoverability is interesting.
The models are very different.
I think one of the
super powers of the web
is the fact that discovery
is frictionless, and easy,
and universal.
Everything's a click away.
There's no install process.
There's no gatekeeper.
You can just click a link,
and you're in the experience.
And so in some ways, as
the web evolves on mobile,
we'd like to preserve the
qualities of the web that
make it amazing and make that
work on these new form factors.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
So I guess just
quick follow-up would
be, I think that
people who are wrapping
web technology in Cordova,
to some extent, that's
for capability.
But I'd say that maybe
even a majority of those
are sheerly for app
store distribution,
so that you have the
placement in the same place
that people already expect
to look from a web app.
So while those things
will change over time,
how do you think about that?
Do you like packaging
things with Cordova,
or is that a stopgap to a
future where we don't need to?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I
think you're right.
The app store model
works really, really
well for content discovery.
Will Google ever build a
content discovery service
for the web, some
kind of engine?
DARIN FISHER: Let me
Google that for you.
[LAUGHTER]
JAKE ARCHIBALD: For search?
But I think it's a
fair point, though,
is we are seeing people going
to these app store models
even though we have
the websites there
that should be doing that job.
RAHUL ROY-CHOWDHURY:
I think we don't
need to be prescriptive
about that.
I think developers,
such as yourselves,
know your use case
better than anyone else.
And you should decide
what makes sense.
If discovery through
clicking a link
on social media, for
example, is the right way
for your application to
be discovered and used
by many people, the web is
probably the right model to go.
If you value the packaging
aspect of the store,
or you feel like you will get
a chance of being retained
on the home screen by
the user and thus get
higher re-engagement, the store
is a good model to consider.
I feel like there is
no one size fits all.
One of the themes that
you heard yesterday
was that we've seen increasingly
that the store model and app
installs on the home screen
are great for a small set
of [? head ?] applications.
And people engage
those applications
with high levels of engagement.
But for the long
tail, it's not clear
that you will get the engagement
that you're hoping for,
potentially, if there's
many other apps installed
on the device.
And for those users or
for those developers,
maybe the web is
a superior model.
So it kind of depends
on a case-by-case basis
what the needs of
your application are.
GRACE KLOBA: And I
just want to add on
that one is the
Chrome for Android,
and I think also Chrome for iOS,
there's an Add to Home Screen.
So if the user really wants to
use the website all the time,
they can easily
add to home screen,
and it's easy to access it.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I think
another one of the things
that people like
about the Play Store
is it provides a really
low-barter monetization.
What can we do to make
the web competitive here?
AVNI SHAH: Yeah,
that's a good question.
I'll take a stab at this,
and other people can jump in.
So payment models
and monetization--
clearly important
for the mobile web.
I think it's a huge pain
point for all of you.
It's actually a huge pain
point for users, too.
There's a bunch of different
solutions out there.
A lot of people are actually
interested in the space.
And there's not one
clear answer here, yet.
With some of the solutions we've
seen, one of the things we see
is that the more friction
for integration and things
like that lead to lower uptake.
And therefore, it's
harder to get something
that works across
the web at large.
But it is something that
we care a lot about,
something we're
thinking a lot about.
I think there's things we
can do here to make things
like AutoFill, which is
technology we already have--
it's already built
into the platform--
work well, either by encouraging
developers to do things
like simply tag fields
and things like that,
much better than
is happening today.
So I think there
are some solutions
we can do to make the friction
lower for users and for all
of you.
So stay tuned.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Let's take a
question from the audience.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
I'm not sure if you're the
right group to ask this,
but it's probably as
close as I'm going to get.
So Node.js relies on
V8 heavily, and it
doesn't seem like Google is
too involved with that project.
I was wondering if there's
any talks with maybe extending
a long-term,
long-support version
of the V8 engine
for Node purposes?
GREG SIMON: What
sort of improvements
do you think we could make
to V8 to make Node better?
AUDIENCE: No, V8 is great.
It's just sometimes Node lags
behind on the V8 versions.
I was just wondering if
you were maybe working on
GREG SIMON: Yeah,
that's probably
something to talk to the
Node project authors about.
I mean, V8 is a public API,
and we love that Node uses it.
It's really great.
But yeah, the V8 team's
not responsible for rolling
V8 versions into Node.
JAKE ARCHIBALD:
But it'd be great
if they did it,
because then you'd
get Promises and then
Generators with that, as well.
The Node team-- I
think that there
is a lot of API discussion
around Promises there,
but I'd love them
to take that on,
especially now it's
part of the platform.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: This is
my favorite question.
If you look at Google Docs
and Inbox in other browsers,
you get a banner telling
you to use Chrome.
Or in Inbox's case, the
site is entirely blocked.
And that is even in
Chromium-based browsers,
such as Opera.
Internet Explorer just launched
Skype for the web cross
browser.
When did Google
become the bad guys?
[WHISTLING]
[LAUGHTER]
AVNI SHAH: Can we
debate the premise
of the last part
of that question?
[LAUGHTER]
Throw that out there.
RAHUL ROY-CHOWDHURY: Yeah,
that's a loaded question.
But I think we would like
things to be cross-browser.
As I said, the
superpower of the web
is the fact that it works
across different browsers,
different form factors.
It's ubiquitous.
Chrome cares deeply
about making that true.
In the case of
Inbox, I'm not sure
why they're targeting
Chrome specifically.
It could be a QA thing.
It could be just
a phase rollout.
But certainly, we would love
for all Google properties
to run on all browsers.
Maybe there's some caveats
around Evergreen browsers
versus non-updating browsers.
But generally
speaking, we would like
to see that happen, as well.
I don't think
there's any conflict.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So I guess
it's slightly-- oh, sorry.
Go for it.
AUDIENCE: So one thing that's
come up during this conference
is that it seems like there
is a deeper integration now
between V8 and the
rendering runtime.
I've heard that now there's
integration between Blink
and V8, such that if there is
time at the end of rendering
each frame, that will
potentially trigger a GC pause,
so it'll use the
idle time better.
And I'm wondering if
there's any incentive
to start to open up more
of those browser internals
to user script, user JavaScript.
Because that GC
pause, for example,
makes it challenging to
begin to write applications
in [? ready-to-use ?] WebGL,
because you just never know
when you're going to
hit that GC Pause.
So you're running WebGL
inside of the user
thread in JavaScript, and it
can interrupt your animation.
And that means that
it's much harder to--
GREG SIMON: It's true.
I don't think we'll
ever expose a GC Now
or Don't GC, because
that would be abused
and suddenly RAM would be
even worse than it is today.
The best way you can control
a garbage-collected system
as a developer is
to not recreate
objects, which is
not a great answer.
As far as primitives, we are
in total agreement with you.
Over the past year, we sort
of had a team agreement
that we weren't
going to do anything
more that's high level.
Instead, let's try to
rationalize a platform.
And so if you look
at Service Worker,
you can use it to
describe App Cache,
because that's what
we should have shipped
is Service Worker,
not App Cache.
And so you're going to
see a lot more of that,
of like lower-level,
simpler primitives
that other frameworks
can start to use,
rather than just
Show Modal Dialogue.
DARIN FISHER:
Plus, on blink-dev,
you can follow along.
There's a project
called Oilpan, which
is redoing the
garbage-collection
infrastructure in Blink.
And part of that
creates an opportunity
to do precise GC when
the stack unwinds
and things of this sort.
And we might be able to get
a lot better at scheduling
this work.
The cool thing about that
is that as a developer,
you can start to count on,
if you aren't allocating
too many objects,
then you don't have
to worry about garbage
collection happening
at certain times.
And if you're trying to prepare
a render function for WebGL,
then you'd be thinking about
how many objects you're
creating and so on.
GREG SIMON: Yeah,
that is a great point.
While V8 is garbage-collected
and the V8 team can actually
control when it runs, which is
how they were able to wire it
up to the compositor, Blink
uses a ref counting system.
So things are free and just sort
of in a random order, but not
a predictable order, certainly
not by the web developer.
But by switching away
from the ref counting
system to a graph,
which we can trace,
we'll have much more
control over when
we free things in
Blink, as well.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So why
is it that the two latest
devices from Android
won't have a browser,
like what you were
talking about,
the watches and Android TV?
Have we given up on the web?
[LAUGHTER]
GREG SIMON: Wow.
AVNI SHAH: No.
[LAUGHTER]
DARIN FISHER: You want
the mic to say that?
AVNI SHAH: No, not really.
Greg, you wanna take that one?
GREG SIMON: Yeah, go ahead.
GRACE KLOBA: I will take
the first part, I think.
I mean, I'm wearing
the watch, but there's
no way I can use a
browser on this watch.
So I think the
different devices,
there's a different purpose.
Watch is more of
collecting the data,
and then also for
the notification.
So for example,
our Service Worker
is going to be able
to lie it aside,
pushing the notification
to the watch, which
is coming in the M40 frame.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: M41?
GRACE KLOBA: 41?
OK.
Sometimes.
Yeah, push notification,
one is coming.
So for the TV,
there's no browser,
but there's another Chromecast,
which is old browser.
All you get is a browser, right?
GREG SIMON: Yeah, I don't
think of a measure of Chrome's
success-- that actual
binaries on everything.
I want to make sure
that you guys can
reach all these devices.
DARIN FISHER: And a
lot of these devices
can be used in conjunction
with other devices.
The watch is most certainly
a companion device.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So this is a
question coming from Twitter,
and it uses words longer
than I'm normally used to.
"How do you reconcile
philosophically
with material design potentially
limiting the future of UX
by becoming the de
facto root of it?"
AUDIENCE: What?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
AVNI SHAH: Really?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: That
was a lot of words.
DARIN FISHER: Can
you read that again?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: No,
I don't think I can.
I was so happy to
get through it once.
OK, I think what
the question is is,
if material design becomes the
standard for design of the web,
are we losing
innovation in designs?
AVNI SHAH: I think this came
up in the material design panel
at the end, which I
luckily caught the end of.
So I'll just repeat
what they said,
which is that material
design provides
a framework for building
your applications,
but it doesn't necessarily
limit differentiation,
and it doesn't limit what you
can do with your application.
It's just trying to
give you building blocks
and starter blocks for
building beautiful apps.
So I think it's an
important toolkit,
but no, it shouldn't
limit innovation.
GREG SIMON: Yeah,
it's totally optional.
And Polymer is totally optional.
When you sit down in front
of Xcode for iOS or Eclipse
for Java, you have a theme.
You have some kind of opinion
of how things should look.
So you can always choose
to go off and just draw
your own stuff, but the
web doesn't have that.
It's just white.
And so this is a theme,
and it's something.
JAKE ARCHIBALD:
So next question.
"What is the future of Dart?
It feels like it's
in a kind of limbo
at the moment, which
may be putting off
people who are looking
for something like it.
Are there plans to add
the runtime to Chrome?"
DARIN FISHER: So nothing new
to say about the runtime,
but the Dart team is very
committed to Dart to JS.
They're rolling out a
bunch of new enhancements,
like incremental
compilation and so on.
The Dartium project,
which is there
for developers to have faster
turnaround for development,
the Dart team is very
committed to helping
make the Dart development
process great.
So that's pretty much it.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: And when
will Service Workers
come to the WebView on Android?
So when will native
apps be able to leverage
the power of the Service
Worker within them?
DARIN FISHER: Well,
we are working on it.
GRACE KLOBA: Yeah,
that's definitely true.
DARIN FISHER: And the
WebView does auto-update.
Yesterday that got
a round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
JAKE ARCHIBALD:
Are we just going
to run for that for
the rest of the panel?
We'll just keep saying,
WebView auto-updates.
[APPLAUSE]
The WebView-- oh, no, I'm
not going to do it again.
It did actually occur
to me yesterday--
well, when WebView did
start to auto-update,
I was like, oh, well,
yeah, about time.
But it's easy to forget that
it's still the first platform
to do that.
I don't think that there is any
mobile operating system that
has an updating
internal WebView.
GRACE KLOBA: Doesn't
iOS update [INAUDIBLE]?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: iOS.
But that's with the
operating system.
Yeah, we already had that.
GRACE KLOBA: Not at the
six weeks frequency.
GREG SIMON: You are correct.
Thank you.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So NPAPI.
What are the latest plans
for the deprecation of that?
RAHUL ROY-CHOWDHURY: Yes.
So if folks have been
following along with our plans,
we had, earlier in
the year, announced
that we would stop supporting
NPAPI by default in Chrome
by the end of this year.
And in fact, we are actually
reviewing and looking
at all the usage
data as we speak.
And there will be a blog post
that goes out early next week.
So if you're interested
in this topic,
come and find me afterwards,
or look out for the blog post
next week.
But the quick summary is,
usage data is trending down,
as often, [? PPAPI ?] plug-ins,
as we were hoping it would do.
But I think that
we need a couple
more months of enabling it
in Chrome just to make sure
that the last few
developers are coming in hot
are able to get their
changes in place.
So it's looking
like we will keep it
on for another few
months into 2015
but then turn it off by
default in a couple of months
after the end of the year.
So that's basically
the one slight tweak
to what we had
talked about earlier.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Chrome has its
own sort of internal version
of the Flash player,
so removing NPAPI
isn't going to stop Flash.
Is that correct?
RAHUL ROY CHOWDHURY:
That's correct.
Flash is separate from
the NPAPI deprecation.
GREG SIMON: Flash
works on Pepper API,
which there's a
funny story about.
You know that little
volume speaker icon
that everyone was
so excited about?
We can't do that with NPAPI.
We need it.
DARIN FISHER: Yeah,
because Pepper's actually
a plug-in API that
can be sandboxed.
It's also the basis
for Native Client.
But because it's
sandboxed, it means
we can actually know when
the thing is playing audio.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So
if we lose NPAPI,
what is that in terms of
actual things on the web?
What are people going
to see disappearing?
Malware.
Good answer.
RAHUL ROY-CHOWDHURY:
Well, not much.
I mean, we've seen the
trend down in usage.
And typically speaking, people
have moved to the alternatives
to NPAPI.
If you're using NPAPI
plug-in, many people
have moved to Native
Client, because they
found that the Native Client
API's built on top of Pepper,
PPAPI, gave them the
API surface they needed.
In many cases, actually,
Chrome extensions
that used NPAPI were
using it to communicate
with a local executable,
like on Windows.
Just, like, you can
imagine a messaging app
that from a web page extension,
can launch a native executable
to bring up the chat window.
And so we introduced APIs in
the Chrome extension system
to handle those
specific use cases.
So for example, there's
a native messaging API.
So if that is the only
reason you were using NPAPI,
you could just move to
the native messaging API
and you'd be fine.
Over the course of
the year, developers
have been sort of
gradually migrating, using
all of these
different techniques.
And there's an NPAPI
deprecation guide, as well.
If you just search for
NPAPI Deprecation Guide,
you'll see a link to
it, which explains
all of the different
ways people can do this.
GREG SIMON: There
are paths for this,
which are even easier than
what you were doing before.
We had a music company
that had an NPAPI
plug-in to talk to
their guitar over USB.
And then they just switched
to the chrome.usb API,
which is easier.
It's not C++ anymore.
It's just JavaScript,
and it worked.
RAHUL ROY-CHOWDHURY:
And WebRTC support
has also helped a great deal.
JAKE ARCHIBALD:
So beyond mobile,
what do we see as
the next big thing?
Is the desktop dead?
Are we just concentrating
fully on mobile now?
AVNI SHAH: The
desktop isn't dead.
On Chrome alone, we have
more than 750 million users
on desktop.
And that was a
stat we announced,
what, like 18 months ago,
so I'll leave that there.
But it's not where
the growth is.
I think Andreessen
Horowitz just released
this slide deck in the
last couple of weeks that
showed the next billion
users to come online
are all going to come
online with smartphones.
And what's interesting
is that they're
going to come online
with smartphones,
and that's going to
be their only device.
It's going to be their first
interaction with the internet,
where for many of us and
for the developed markets,
the smartphone is
second to the desktop.
So that's going to be an
interesting trend, I think.
This is going to be
people's first interaction
with the internet and the
web on a smartphone device.
And what's also interesting
is a lot of these users that
are coming online are coming
online in emerging markets
where things look
very different.
There's flaky connectivity,
or low bandwidth,
or high data costs.
Phones are not
necessarily as powerful.
And so we have to think
about, what should we
do with the platform
in the user experience
to actually make it a
really good experience
for those users?
And another trend we're already
seeing that I'll mention
is just the cross-device trend.
So people are using
multiple devices-- well,
at least here in
developed markets.
But also, if you think
about the emerging markets,
they'll start with
the smartphone
and probably extend to
other devices over time.
And so how can we make
that experience better?
And Chrome is in an interesting
position to do that,
because it crosses
all of these platforms
and can actually help with that.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So HTTPS
is really important,
but developers still find
it hard and expensive.
And Mozilla are launching their
own certificate of authority.
What's Google and Chrome doing?
There's your answer, everyone.
[LAUGHTER]
DARIN FISHER: No, but I
mean, as you heard yesterday,
we're doing a lot to try
to help people understand
how to HTTPS-enable their sites.
And there's just
so many benefits.
And actually, while
it's challenging,
it's not as hard
as it used to be.
There's a lot of resources
out there to help
and a lot of
benefits, definitely
a lot of user benefits.
So basically, our biggest
effort, I would say,
is getting the word out and
helping people understand it.
JAKE ARCHIBALD:
And we're now-- one
of the incentives we've got is
if a site is served securely,
that's part of our
search ranking now.
DARIN FISHER: Oh,
yes, good point.
Actually, yes, that's correct.
What else is there to say?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I'm
receiving live information
from the people who
have been running that,
just to say that the Mozilla
certificate of authority,
because that's
cross-signed by IdenTrust,
then Chrome is going to
be supporting their certs,
as well, which is pretty good.
They pasted that three
times into the Docs,
so I presume it was very
important that I said that.
So thank you, guys.
So cross-browser HTML5
video codec support.
It's been in a pretty
messy state for a while.
Are there any plans to
help standardize this?
Why didn't we turn
off [INAUDIBLE]
since we've got
our own format now?
DARIN FISHER: Things are
definitely messy in the space.
And that's definitely true.
I think our approach has
been through the efforts
with VP8 and VP9 to try to
push forward, open codecs that
offer benefits and
make things better.
We've been working closely
with YouTube to actually have,
like, full-circle experience
here where YouTube
is serving up and seeing
great benefits from using VP9.
It's very exciting.
But from the browser's
point of view,
we're in the reality
where we have
to support both the
new and the old.
And then on the WebRTC side,
it's very interesting, as well.
This has been challenging, too.
There, it's exciting, because--
well, it's interesting.
At the latest IETF
Conference, they just
made an agreement that a
standard WebRTC implementation,
which support both
VP8 and H.264.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So this
next question is rubbish,
but it was asked by the
organizer of this conference,
Paul Kinlan, so I
feel that I have to.
Here we go.
DARIN FISHER: Trying
to make friends.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I can't even
read it with enthusiasm.
What are the top three
priorities for Chrome?
Not two, not four.
Give me arbitrarily
the top three.
RAHUL ROY-CHOWDHURY: All
right, I can take a stab at it.
Even though it is Paul
Kinlan, should we even
answer the question?
So the top one is the theme
of the conference-- making
the web platform
great on mobile.
You heard about all
the things we're
working on to that end--
performance, capabilities.
And so that is a core
priority for us for 2015.
The second is to make the user
experience on mobile devices
better, and
specifically, to blur
the seams between the world of
apps and the world of the web.
And yesterday, you
saw some examples
of that with the Recents
menu in Android L,
where there's a single place
to go back to open Chrome tabs,
as well as open applications.
So users don't have to deal
with the complexity of,
did I open that
thing in a browser,
or was it a native application?
And so that complexity
is taken away.
And so there's much
more work to be
done to make that user
experience seamless.
It's a big focus for us.
And I would say
the third thing--
I guess just because we
have a hard limit of three?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yep,
no more than three.
RAHUL ROY-CHOWDHURY: Is Chrome
has some core principles--
speed, simplicity, security.
They were the
principles we launched
with from the first
version of Chrome.
And so everything we
do, we want to make
sure we stay true
to those principles.
And so that is just
underlying everything we do.
Speed, simplicity,
security will always
be a big priority for us.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I think it's
probably within the rules
to say that you can have three
each if anyone's got any more.
But if you do one, you are
duty-bound to do two more,
because that's the rule.
[LAUGHS] What are the bottom
three priorities for Chrome?
[LAUGHTER]
DARIN FISHER: I think it would
make people sad if we say them.
GREG SIMON: Well, what
are we [? deprecating? ?]
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Chrome apps.
DARIN FISHER: Wait, wait, wait.
So there's Intend to Removes.
There's some Intend to Remove
threads on blink-dev that
can tell you what
we're trying to kill.
RAHUL ROY-CHOWDHURY:
Supporting NPAPI forever
is not a high
priority for the team.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: XSLT.
I guess we're trying to
move to get rid of that.
DARIN FISHER: That actually
gets some people upset.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I went on
an XSLT training course
when I first left university.
I want that to die.
I want to kill it for
just a horrible week
of training I went through.
And then it didn't help
my life at all since then.
GREG SIMON: We've been having a
very lively debate on blink-dev
about some people that want to
take it out and make it some
sort of thing that downloads
later, and then-- but that--
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah,
we should do that.
I think that's just from
a dark time of the web,
where I think that the way the
web was created at that point
was it was just a load of
old men with beards sitting
in a tepee.
And someone would go, we
need a way to transform XML.
And one of them would
go, we'll do it in XML.
[LAUGHTER]
So Chrome apps in APIs.
Chrome apps in APIs has
a credibility problem
since-- sorry. [LAUGHS]
[APPLAUSE]
Oh, my god.
I'm so jet-lagged.
Chrome apps in APIs has
a credibility problem
since few Google properties
actually use them
even for no-brainers like
notification support.
Are we in for the long
haul with Chrome apps?
RAHUL ROY-CHOWDHURY:
Yeah, we are.
So there are a couple
of Google properties
that have built great Chrome
app experiences-- Play Movies,
for example, and Play Music.
Unlike many other
sort of platforms,
the Chrome app platform is
really the native development
platform for Chrome OS.
And so Chrome OS has been
doing great, particularly
in Enterprise and EDU markets.
And so if that's an interesting
segment for developers
or for any of you
to target, I think
you should look at
whether a Chrome
app is the right choice for you.
The other thing I'll
mention is, we love the web.
Chrome OS loves the web.
And so Chrome apps was not
meant to be a place where
you would build an application
if it could work well
on the web.
It is meant to be a place where
you needed to do something that
wasn't available at the
web maybe at the time,
or maybe the security
model wasn't exactly right.
An example of this
is Chrome apps
has had a Bluetooth
API for a while.
So if you need a
Bluetooth access
and you're targeting
Chromebook devices,
that was really the only
way you could do it.
We're working on bringing
that same API to the web.
You heard discussions
about that earlier.
But it takes a while to
understand the security
model and the
implications of it.
But Chrome apps
are here to stay.
Chrome OS is something
we're very committed to.
And this is the native
platform for Chromebooks.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So
we're approaching
the end of the set
of questions we have.
We've only got a
couple more left.
So yes, if we have
questions from the audience,
we will take them.
If there's any
answers you've been
unhappy with that you want
to pressure these guys for
or anything, that's OK.
Please don't fire me.
We'll go to the
audience for a question.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, can I
follow up that question?
Once there is permissions,
Service Workers, manifests,
and all that, is there still
a future for Chrome apps?
RAHUL ROY-CHOWDHURY: I think
the line we want to make
is that if things work well on
the web, even for Chromebooks,
we'd like it to be on the web.
I think the web is the right
experience for all the reasons
we talked about over
the last couple of days.
There may be some cases in which
having your UI, for example,
being a browser tab is
not the right experience.
Maybe there's an API that's
not available on the web.
Maybe the packaging model
is superior, just based
on what you've done in
the past, your skill set.
For those reasons,
a Chrome app may
be the right choice for you.
And so we will continue
to support Chrome apps,
and we'll continue to make
sure that Chrome OS always
has a native platform that
developers can target.
Imagine in the
future, for example,
that there's a new Chromebook
device that has a new sensor,
for example, and you
want to understand
how to get data
from that sensor.
Chrome apps will
always be the way
you can target all of the
capabilities of those devices,
whereas on the web, it may take
a while to get to that point.
GREG SIMON: Yes, but it should
be much faster on the web.
And we're trying to
do that with things
like Navigator Connect
and permissions.
But totally, I agree.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I suppose
that things like Chrome apps
become a good sort of
testing ground, don't they?
For not only how an API
for a particular thing,
maybe say Bluetooth,
how that would look.
But it's also a good test to
see how much usage it gets.
That's good feedback
for us to see
what should be pushing
to the web platform.
RAHUL ROY-CHOWDHURY:
Yeah, not only usage,
but also just the
technical challenges
that the Chrome
Apps team has faced
is really informing a
lot of the work that's
happening with
Service Worker and all
of these new APIs coming
to the web, as well.
DARIN FISHER:
Interestingly, some
of the same people who've
worked on Chrome apps
and who are working
on Chrome apps
are also contributing
APIs, like Bluetooth,
and like Push
notifications, and things
built around Service
Worker, because this
is a space that they've
been thinking about,
understanding in the
context of Chrome apps.
But they can also apply that
understanding and experience
to the open web.
And we're very
excited about that.
I think that, to me, Chrome
App serves this distinct place
that's been this place
where, like Rahul said,
we've been able to put
out features quickly.
And in the context
of Chrome apps,
the security model's different.
It allows for just these sort
of things to work simply.
But we are very
committed to trying
to find ways to bring a lot of
this functionality to open web
to allow people
to take advantage
of device capabilities
and so on.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So are there
particular plans to standardize
things like Chrome.serial,
chrome.bluetoothLowEnergy,
.usb storage, the rich
notification stuff?
DARIN FISHER: I think we're
taking these gradually
and thoughtfully.
RAHUL ROY-CHOWDHURY:
I think I heard
Mike put it well
earlier, when he said,
Bluetooth is one of the
hairiest ones to get right.
If you can get that
right, the other things
will kind of fall
out, and you'll
find a pattern
that you can reuse.
So Bluetooth is the one
we're working on currently.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I've seen
some really interesting work
by Scott Jensen, who's
been looking at Beacons.
Thank you.
But where they just
transmit a URL.
And there, it becomes
suddenly as, oh, hang on,
there's lots we can
do with just that.
We can roll that into
the web if we have some--
DARIN FISHER: I'm
actually very excited
about the connection
between these two topics
that we were just talking about.
Like, for example, if you had
that URL pointing to a website,
who, actually, that
website knew how
to use this future
Bluetooth API to talk back
to the physical
device, you can start
to imagine some
possibilities here.
The ephemeral nature of
URLs and such is awesome.
The idea that you
just walk into a room
and you find out that there's
some URLs you can load
to now interact with some
actual physical objects,
and that the
interaction with them
can be actually really rich,
because you can actually
make more direct
device connections that
are accustomed to that device,
using things like Bluetooth
or other device APIs that
we might bring support
in the future.
JAKE ARCHIBALD:
We've already been
bouncing around crazy ideas,
like if a website can register
to be background-aware
of these Beacon URLs
for a particular origin or
start with a particular path,
then you would walk near
one of these things,
and it could spin
up a Service Worker.
And it could fire an event
in that Service Worker.
And you can then do
what you want, do
some caching, short
notification, just
all with the open web.
DARIN FISHER: In
fact, this whole model
I'm excited about, because it
can help solve some security
problems, because
the interaction
model is very precise.
A user is interacting
with a particular device,
and therefore, some hard
problems get solved.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: This is a
nice question to end on.
How do we see Chrome coexisting
with platforms like Android
in the next five years?
AVNI SHAH: Oh, sure.
I guess I'll start by saying, if
I could predict five years out,
I'd be lying, because
things change a lot.
DARIN FISHER: Or
you'd be really rich.
AVNI SHAH: Yeah, or I'd be
really rich, one of the two,
and I wouldn't be here.
Um.
[LAUGHTER]
JAKE ARCHIBALD: What?
GREG SIMON: What?
AVNI SHAH: I didn't say that.
Don't fire me.
Um.
A lot changes in five years.
Five years ago, Chrome
was only a year old.
Chrome for Android didn't exist.
Chrome for iOS didn't exist.
I mean, the world changes
a lot in five years,
so trying to predict five
years out is near impossible,
especially at the rate of
change that we're seeing.
But I think, given
that, we're going
to continue to make the web on
mobile a really good platform
for developers, like, make
it a great way for you
to reach users, improve
the capabilities,
improve the performance.
I don't think this
is necessarily
like a zero-sum game
between native and web.
I think both are really
strong platforms.
And as developers, you're going
to choose what's right for you,
and I think they're going
to coexist for a while.
Five years?
I don't know.
Maybe-- I don't
know-- spaceships
will be landing over here.
I don't know what's
going to happen.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: And they'll have
web browsers installed on them.
Yep.
AVNI SHAH: Yeah, of
course they will.
Yeah.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: We'll go to
a question from the audience.
AUDIENCE: Just a
closing question.
Is there going to be a place
where we can see the slide
decks, and the
videos, and stuff?
Is that going to be
made available for this?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Did a
member of the Google team
give you that question?
That's great.
Well, one of the
fantastic things, I think,
is that up on YouTube now,
the videos from yesterday have
already been edited and
put up as separate things
to watch, which is brilliant.
The same will happen with
today's sessions very soon.
And we'll make sure
that the slide decks
are linked from there, as well.
DARIN FISHER: This session, too?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah, afraid so.
And captions.
So it will be searchable.
They might cut out
the odd bit of mine.
[LAUGHS] I think if we make
the same kind of progress
that we've made in the past five
years in the next five years,
then the future's looking
pretty bright, right?
RAHUL ROY-CHOWDHURY: Yeah.
DARIN FISHER: Yeah.
AVNI SHAH: Yeah.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Cool.
Well, that seems like a
great place to end it.
A huge thanks to the
leadership panel.
[APPLAUSE]